we've been using the 2018 iPad pro since
it came out almost a year and a half ago
and one thing's for certain it's been
through a lot so let's examine the
history of this iPad pro and how our
personal thoughts on it have changed as
software has evolved and brought us into
2020 now we are expecting a new 20/20
iPad pro within the next couple of
months which we discussed in that video
which you can check out after this one
but I personally believe that the 2018
model is gonna sell like hotcakes even
after the 2020 model comes out let's
talk about why there are five main
features of this iPad pro that greatly
added to its success and they're also
the features that really matter for 2020
and beyond but before I get into these
features I want to quickly go through
how this iPad pro has evolved since
release in my very first review of the
2018 iPad pro less than two weeks after
release my thoughts were mostly negative
I mentioned that it was a mistake for
Apple to market the iPad pro as a
computer replacement when the software
was so limiting even though they added
the USB C port you couldn't connect a
flash drive or an external storage drive
file imports were limited to photos only
using an SD card adapter and it forced
you to use the Photos app to do it they
also added external display support but
it basically only mirrored your display
so you still have to touch your iPad to
control it because at that time there
was no Mouse support the 11 inch model
also had a brand new aspect ratio which
meant that most apps and games couldn't
use up the full display until they were
updated to specifically support the 2018
11 inch model and in terms of
performance even though the 2018 iPad
pro is much faster than the 2017 model
they both felt exactly the same because
they were barely any apps that could
utilize the 2018 models full power
so basically when this iPad pro was
released it honestly wasn't worth buying
and then came I pad OS which completely
changed the game for the iPad pro
external drives now work perfectly fine
allowing you to freely drag and drop
files to in from the iPad pro you can
even edit photos and videos
directly off of a drive without first
having to import it onto your iPads
local storage not only that but you can
now log on to a storage server
wirelessly using SMB we did this
ourselves and we were able to easily
access the files on our server apple
also updated split view so that you can
now open two instances of the same app
right next to each other making it a
whole lot more useful alongside that
they added new gestures for text
selection and undoing mistakes which
make it much easier to use Safari added
a new Downloads folder feature allowing
you to download PDFs and other files off
the internet and quickly use and edit
them Apple even added full keyboard
shortcut support so that using your iPad
smart keyboard actually felt like using
a MacBook a huge bonus for artists and
Apple pencil users was that the pencils
latency was reduced from 20 milliseconds
to only nine which made it feel even
more like a real pencil along with that
Apple finally added Mouse support now
while it's not perfect and it works
similarly to how touch controls work it
allows you to set your iPad aside when
using it with an external display these
new iPad OS features changed everything
about the iPad pro and has started to
make us question whether it could
actually replace a laptop so we compared
them to last year's base MacBook Air and
MacBook Pro our conclusion was that for
the first time ever the iPad pro
actually makes a lot of sense to buy
compared to a laptop it's got tons of
power and excellent display great
battery life great portability and it's
actually very functional with the new
iPad OS features giving you awesome
multitasking and file management
capabilities while also giving you
access to the massive database of iOS
apps and games and then came Mac OS
Catalina which allowed users to connect
their Mac to their iPad pro using the
new sidecar feature for things like art
and productivity so now here we are in
2020 and the great news is that since
the release of iPad OS the 2018 iPad pro
has continued to get better and better
now almost all apps that we've tried
support the
aspect ratio perfectly new apps like the
full desktop version a Photoshop are now
available and they do a great job of
supporting the iPad pro like for example
supporting the second-generation Apple
pencils new DoubleTap feature we've
noticed that more and more apps and
games are now utilizing more of the iPad
pros immense performance allowing users
to really feel the extra power not only
that but there are now more games that
support the iPad pros 120 Hertz display
like fortnight which recently added 120
FPS support to the 2018 iPad pro and let
me tell you it works incredibly well so
while it seemed ridiculous at launch
that Apple packed in so much power into
this iPad pro were actually extremely
glad that they did because it's still
very powerful even with the latest apps
and games that are being released today
and just recently Microsoft Outlook
finally added the long-awaited
side-by-side multitasking support so you
can now have two of the same Microsoft
app open side-by-side and if you look on
Amazon you'll see a bunch of USBC Docs
for the iPad pro really giving users
more freedom to connect whatever devices
they'd like to companies like Bridge are
now coming out with iPad pro keyboards
that feature track pads to make them
more and more like actual Mac books and
if Apple decides to add curser support
to a future iPad OS update these new
keyboards will be incredibly useful so
now that we know how drastically the
iPad pro has evolved since its release
let's get into the five main features
that I think really matter for 2020 and
beyond first off the main feature that
really sets the 2018 iPad pro apart is
the design the square edges in Slate
shape make it really unique compared to
any other iPad it's also the only iPad
to get rid of the home button and switch
to face ID giving us a display with even
bezels and rounded corners this makes
using this iPad pro a whole different
experience compared to using any other
iPad and that is what really matters
going into 2020 and if the rumors are
true about the 20/20 I phones coming
with a new square edge design the 2018
iPad pro is gonna feel perfectly at home
and not outdated at all the second main
feature that really matters is the
performance even though the new iPhone
11 Pro is using the latest Apple chip
it's actually still slower than the iPad
pro in both processor and graphics
performance it's actually so high that
even after a year and a half it can
easily chew through any app or game on
the App Store without any performance
issues so that gives us consumers a lot
of confidence going into 20/20 knowing
that we can truly rely on this iPad pro
the third main feature is the display
while most of the new higher-end ipads
come with the same retina quality
displays very low reflectivity an
excellent touch support the iPad pro
gets a major advantage and I'm not
talking about the brighter 600 nits
display compared to 500 on the others
but I'm talking about the fact that the
iPad pro gets the incredible once when
he hurts promotion technology this
basically means that the display can
dynamically adjust its own refresh rate
between 24 Hertz and 120 Hertz based on
the content you're viewing so if you're
watching a movie the display refreshes
at 24 Hertz which will save battery life
and if you're on the home screen or
playing a game with 120 FPS support
you're getting super fluid animations
that you just can't get on any other
iPad tablet or even macbook and seeing
as more apps and games are starting to
support 120 FPS this pro motion feature
is gonna get even better going into 2020
and beyond now the fourth feature is
actually the USB C port unlike any other
iPad the 2018 iPad pro is able to easily
connect to an external display using USB
C you can also buy a USB C dock and get
access to a bunch of ports that you
can't get on a regular iPad and what's
special about us PC is that it's able to
supply power to external flash drives
and storage drives allowing you to
easily transfer files which is much more
complicated on a lightning packin iPad
having this USB C port makes the 2018
iPad pro much more capable going into
2020 and it's gonna allow it to compete
with the upcoming iPad pro refresh much
easier than
it was still packing a lightning port
finally on to the fifth main feature
which admittedly isn't really a feature
but is still a really big deal and
that's the price we've seen this iPad
pro go as low as six hundred and
seventy-five dollars brand-new on Amazon
that's a whole 125 bucks off retail
price and in a couple of months when the
new model comes out there's a
possibility that it could drop even
lower maybe as low as six hundred to six
hundred and twenty-five dollars
brand-new and at that price you're
seriously getting so much bang for your
buck we're talking an iPad that's so
good that it competes with laptops so I
can imagine every 2018 iPad pro getting
snatched up off of Amazon as the new
2020 models come out because it's still
gonna be that good going into 2020 and
beyond so there you guys have it that's
our review of the 2018 iPad pro in 2020
if you enjoy this video go ahead and
check out that video right there of the
iPad pro playing fortnight at 120 frames
per second and if you're not already
subscribed click that circle above so
you don't miss out on our 20/20 iPad pro
coverage when it finally gets released
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]